now I'm not actually personally a
hardcore singularitarians which may
surprise some of you but I've always
been very intrigued by the concept and
took it on as a sort of a challenge to
see if I could write a meaningful
fictional story about that would be set
after the singularity and that led to to
these books starting with the quantum
thief and it's sequels and as I was
writing them I became aware of this
Russian thinker called Nikolai Fedorov
who'd sort of anticipated ideas that
sounded very much like the modern idea
of the singularity already back in the
1890s and in the quantum feedbacks that
was just a little side note but after
finishing the books I kind of was was
intrigued by it and started wondering
whether there had been times in the past
where it felt like the singularity was
coming and and what did those what did
what did you feel like living those
times and it turned out that this was
very much the case and the result was my
recent novel Summerland
which just came out it is a spy story
set in an alternate world where a very
different kind of singularity has has
taken place
scientists have proven that the
afterlife is real and can be contacted
by a radio and it was inspired by
real-life Victorian spiritualists ideas
from four dimensional geometry and
etheric physics and today I want to tell
you more about all those crazy ideas and
tell you some stories from real history
and maybe we can discuss all together
what those stories can teach us about
our present-day worries and hopes about
the singularity so to start with let's
go back to back in time 180 years - to
1838 and to the invention of the
electric telegraph and so 180 years ago
Samuel Morse sent the first telegram in
the United States and that was across
just two miles of telegraph wire but
Telegraph sort of exploded
at an exponential rate and just ten
years later there was 6,000 miles of
telegraph cable in the United States so
it's 6,000 miles in just 10 years and
Tom Standage has actually called the
Telegraph Network the Victorian Internet
and I think that's a very good parallel
there was this explosion of growth Wild
West period of sort of different
competing technologies and different
companies and ultimately sort of
consolation when the Western Western
Telegraph Union was formed and it became
sort of a Google of its time and by the
year 1900 it controlled a million miles
of telegraph lines now very close to
where Western Union was headquartered in
Rochester was a small town called
Heights Ville and in March 31st 1848
something quite strange happened there
these these two sisters Kate and
Margaret Fox started receiving messages
from the afterlife and the messages came
as rapping noises that that that had a
code so sort of multiple raps for no one
rap for yes so quite a lot like the
Morse code in the telegraph and
initially the girls told their family
that the messages came from this
creature called mr. split foot maybe
maybe the devil but later sort of
changed their story and said it was the
spirit of a peddler who had been
murdered in there and in their home and
as it happened the Fox family was
friends with a quite an influential
radical Quaker family that lived in
Rochester and and they and the Quakers
got very very excited about the
possibility of directly communicate with
the dead and and they sort of formed
what became the core of the spiritualist
movement and suddenly there was this
explosion of mediums the Fox sisters got
hundreds of imitators they themselves
became very famous and Horace Greeley
the newspaper man and politician sort of
took took them under his wing and the
timing was sort of right for something
like this the US was going through what
is now known as the Second Great
Awakening and that was kind of a
Protestant religious revival that
emphasized a personal relationship with
God sort of came with fascination with
supernatural
and Romanticism so people got very
excited when suddenly there was this
what you could describe as an open
source religion that promised direct
lines of communication with the dead and
because the early spiritualists were
associated with groups like Quakers and
and Universalists they were also very
much into social reforms abolition of
slavery women's rights and so on and and
mediums actually mostly women so so that
sort of gave them a new kind of voice
that helped drive some of those those
issues but when I kind of looked into
this what really surprised me was how
closely the language used to describe
mediums I was associated with telegraphy
so here's a period drawing that
describes a spiritual Telegraph sort of
crossing the Atlantic and some mediums
actually started using Telegraph
transmission hardware so so they first
they took took sort of existing
telegraph hardware to to channel spirits
and then actually started building their
own hardware for for contacting spirits
so so here's here's one one example
which is an alphabet wheel for
communicating with the dead but it's
actually modeled after a contemporary
with stone design some of the Erik wants
the early alphabet wheels that made it
easier for a telegraph operators read
read the incoming message so there's
this very interesting feedback loop
between between the the hardware that
the mediums used and the hardware that
the telegraph operators used
[Music]